how's Gumrah is my spear path welcome to
shadow of Mordor there's people in there
how does that work so I got the
opportunity to check out the games come
demo of this game we are together now
you and I gonna go on a low org hunt
that's what my girlfriend says when I
forget to buy our chocolate chief
soldiers will be yours she's in lovely I
am your mission we're gonna go like I
said on it or [ __ ] so we have to find
five different war chiefs and kill them
and they all have a little bodyguards as
you can see so I actually have the rare
celebrity version up this is Tara Reid
that's Michael Jackson Justin Bieber
they're all here um I think we're gonna
start with beeps so we need to kill a
lot of these orcs to kind of draw him
out all right let's get over there but
wait I want to go face I'll fast sanic
faced oh yeah hey what's up what's my
name
I'm serious what's my name I don't know
it in this game I can actually control
orcs kind of like the force hi hey let
me control him there you go so now he's
with me
Team Jacob I agree Jacob so yeah we need
to head over there let's go there but I
want to go fast how fast sanic face
oh that was nice and dandy what are you
doing here Barris
I knew it the Bears are working from
Lourdes you're all right let's get this
man
this gentleman ah he killed himself well
I guess he knew what was coming
oh god he's running away it's getting in
the alarm not today sir
Oh Oh tonight Jesus Christ look at his
madness there's so many goodbye Oh
ha ha look at this [ __ ] it I'm like one
versus a million look at his [ __ ] for us
I'm a boss oh I drink sauce oh wow
not his sauce this is weird they're too
many there's just too many not today sir
ha ha well let's try and pushed him off
the bridge - maybe yes that works ha ha
oh oh I gave him a new haircut no
wonderful even though he's bald he got a
new haircut
that really hurts my feelings mainly
you're not even look upon our master why
is too cute for you it doesn't want me
to look at his bay almost 35 oh my god
come on we can do this price ok I don't
[ __ ] up now yeah he's here now we just
have to kill him please we'll meet again
oh my god his final form has finally
been revealed it's a rare sight to see
beeps without makeup
babes I got your name on my sword cake
would you I will take all of your five
nips
goodbye rheems yes
we're tech oh my god oh so hard yeah we
got one of those awesome I am so proud
Oh myself we can still have fun with
these guys you want to have some fun
Oh orcs they wanna have fun oh oh they
just want to have fun you guys are my
brace friends we like to hug
we like to shank I'm bi we're such good
friends you you never had a friendship
until you had a stab each other in the
back of literally friendship fraud it's
my favorite all right let's go for Tara
Reid
this time the [ __ ] are you guys my god
it should not be allowed to be this ugly
oh okay all right
these are awesome rez oh god oh god oh
god okay haha you're my [ __ ] now
oh damn lazy you can really climb guys
beads alright you go and have some fun
are you doing is he hiding in the bushes
you're not a bush lazy I keep telling Oh
God okay so kill without taking damage
oh my god are you insane
Lizzie how are we gonna do this Lizzie
Lizzie Lizzie oh god yeah be lazy every
time alright 20 ropes without taking
damage we should probably take like a
stealth approach good night
three and that's five I'm sorry mate I
know you thought we were friends but I
don't have any friends 17 come on bro
ChaCha's goodbye one more one more one
more just one more please this mission
is like in partner no what are you doing
yes
yeah oh my god now he comes that was now
she comes sorry Tara you're here I'm
gonna look in fab as always I was
sharknado
it looks like sharknado 2 took a toll on
her all right so he's green which means
we can [ __ ] with him and I do like
[ __ ] with him
oh hey oh my god oh god oh god he's
pissed
oh girl that grammar is just amazing oh
god they have back up come on I love how
they have like British accent it really
fits their teeth no offence my speech
yeah my blade in your gizzard are you
talking about having sex with me
we'll wait again right oh no he's
retreating [ __ ] that no you're coming
with me sir
- ya got Tara
I got Tara I got ya oh come on don't run
away with the party's getting started
that's not cool
you [ __ ] piece of Shack whoa oh my
god this game as having weird effects on
me all right breasts I gotta have to end
it air and we got half of it as I press
that was all for me if you want to check
out this game by live a link to it first
thing in the description thank you for
liking and commenting on this video as
always frozen thank you for hanging out
with me today I had a lot of fun playing
this game so I hope you did as well as
always shayok jump rose Brophy